(suspenseful music)
- I love Monsters, Inc.
And I love Mike Wazowski.
Sorry.
I had to do it.
First thing we need to do for this cake
is make our little domes.
So I have this cute little mold.
Spray it with some cooking oil.
(upbeat music)
I'm gonna put this on a
baking sheet in the oven
at 350 degrees Fahrenheit
for about 14 minutes.
I'm gonna check it at 10.
Okay, I've got our cakes.
They're out of the oven.
They are nice and cooled.
We are gonna make a
white chocolate ganache
that's gonna go over the top.
We'll add some white chocolate chips,
one can of condensed milk,
three tablespoons of butter.
I'm gonna put this in the microwave
for about 60 to 90 seconds.
Once you get that out of the microwave,
it should be nice and kind of ribbony.
So the last thing we have to
do is add some food coloring.
All right, I think that green looks good.
So now, it is time to pour.
Looks good.
So we're just gonna keep going
while this is still warm.
All right, so while we let those guys set,
I'm gonna dye some buttercream
purple, blue and black.
Last thing I have to prep are Candy Melts.
I believe they use a white
Candy Melt for Mike's eye
and for his horns.
So I am going to just slice one and a half
and that will make his
little ears, horns things.
Now it is time to put one
of these bad boys together.
(playful music)
It looks good.
He's so cute.
I love him so much.
- [Man With Hat] All
right, I'm sorry, Mike.
There wasn't too much ganache.
I really liked it.
- Am I the Mike to your Sulley?
Are you Sulley and I'm Mike?
- No, you're Sulley.
- No, I'm Mike.
- I'm short and I'm funny.
No, I'm Mike.
- Maybe physically I'm bigger than you,
but I'm not able to scare
children as well as you probably.
- What?
So rude.
(laughing)
Get out.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] Oh yes.